sind besonders schwere Fälle auch für
ein Strafverteidiger wenn Kinder Opfer
sind
es ging hier um die Ermordung eines
Kleinkindes
9 Jahre alt
[Musik]
dann berichtet wird das der Kopf eines
jungen abgetrennt wird und das
verglichen wird wie das Abschneiden 1
Stück Marmorkuchen
ohne Gefühlsregung hört sich Oliver es
die Anklage vor dem Landgericht in
Duisburg an der
23-Jährige muss ich für den Mord an dem
neunjährigen sidhartha verantworten ich
konnte es gar nicht glauben dass der
Mensch der da vor mir sitzt dieser Täter
sein soll ein kindliches Gesicht vom
Beruf Kindergärtner an freundliche
Gestalt aber das Gesicht des Bösen ist
er nicht von der Äußerlichkeit geprägt
das Gesicht des Bösen ist das reine im
Leben
und gegen viele Widerstände habe ich den
Fall übernommen und auch durchgezogen
ich bin Hans Reinhardt und bin seit 30
Jahren Rechtsanwalt meine Fachgebiete
sind das Strafrecht das Steuerstrafrecht
und das Arbeitsrecht ich bin allen drei
Fachgebieten ausgewiesener Fachanwalt
weil man hier von morgens bis abends
arbeitet dann hat man den Eindruck an
jeder Ecke lauert das Verbrechen
an jeder Ecke lauert ein Verbrecher
mein Name ist Burkhard Benecken ich bin
Strafverteidiger verteidige quer durch
die klassische Kriminalität und einer
meiner Schwerpunkte sind auch die
sogenannten glaz
[Musik]